let's meet Beetlejuice with his
Halloween costume I'll describe it to
you as best I can and then yeah I wonder
who he is for Halloween he's Howard
Stern look at this oh my goodness this
is
wild he is Howard Stern I think that's
who he is yeah and he's dressed just
like you he's got the baggy
jeans and a black turtleneck I don't
know if you wear turtlenecks but wow
Beetle are you in there who are you I'm
TR to
start little how you doing beat I'm
doing pretty good yeah now is it hard to
talk through that mask me no no that's C
that's for you what is that you say on
your desk oh thank you uh as a matter of
fact there is a giant statue of Beatles
head that he went through to get this
costume really I do this because I would
do this because I have to do this for
you yeah by the way be I have I have the
best way to do this for you look at his
hands yeah he even made up his hands be
is wow he's white be is white white just
like you wow wow be it's so hard to hear
you but I come up with this stuff I
always come up with it you always come
up with the best stuff I know yeah you
would win any contest that's right I
come up with the best contest baby well
you look great and Sean your manager is
here I see and what are you dressed as
what is that you dressed like uh Mich
Myers yeah from Mike Myers from
Halloween is that right yeah yeah oh
plus you got to see my style who what
I'm going to dress like a vampire this
week you're going to dress like a
vampire that's right any this is your
time of year huh yeah cing honey I love
the Howard ster I wish I wish he I wish
he could just rip the mouth open you to
my place you should be I'll be in the
coffin for a week what a coffin yeah I
got a real coffin isn't it really weird
how the lips don't move when the sound
comes out I hear him but it's weird it's
weird it's really weird beat with you in
this costume oh it's very weird yeah
yeah he's excited though Beetle this is
an amazing costume I love the head
though the the oh stop
it well Halloween spirit is definitely
here